while more extraordinary details about
the couple's troubled relationship and
more serious accusations leveled against
the actor which he strenuously denied an
audio clip has been played to the court
this afternoon which was recorded by
Amber Heard in a hotel room in July 2016
and in that recording you can hear
Johnny Depp talking about cutting
himself it was put to him in court by
the Sun newspapers lawyers you were
threatening Amber Heard with a knife he
denied that and said he was threatening
to cut himself we can play that audio
clip to you now why would I do that
GZ don't please do not do that please do
not do that please don't stop
don't worry mark
oh thank you no thank you also been
talked about in court today is something
that's become known as the defecation
incident it was the it happened in the
aftermath of an alleged attack on Amber
Heard by Johnny Depp he had arrived late
to her birthday party her 30th birthday
party in April 2016 she was angry and he
took that as a criticism according to
the some newspapers lawyers he denied
this he was accused of throwing a magnum
bottle of champagne at her which missed
grabbing her by the hair and pushing her
to the floor he said he didn't do any of
that he didn't hurt her but he said it
was possible that he did write a note
which said happy expletive birthday and
it was the morning after her birthday
when a cleaner found feces in the
couples shared bed when Johnny Depp was
told about this and sent photos of it by
the cleaner
he said he initially found it funny
because it was so absurd in a text
message went to the court he described
it as hilarious and it was the first
time he'd laughed it was that laughed so
hard in years he said that it was to him
clearly human feces and couldn't have
come from the couple's two dogs because
they were too small he said he suspected
that it was either
Amber Heard or one of her friends
because they were the ones most likely
to do something as crass as commit an
act like this in his words when his for
Amber Heard friend was confronted on the
phone about this they described it as a
harmless prank and confronting Amber
Heard about about it Johnny Depp is
accused of throwing a telephone at her
at her head it hit her and a photograph
was then shown to the court allegedly
proving this it shows Amber Heard with
bruising to the side of her face mr.
Depp denies that he did this and he says
that this is all part of this fake
dossier of evidence that she has been
compiling he said as part of a hoax as
an insurance policy against him a text
message was also read out to the court
from Johnny Depp to Amber Heard and in
it he said
you never exploitive loved me it was all
just convenient I hope our divorces
quick I will miss our beauty and truth
goodbye he is expected to finish giving
evidence within the next half an hour
and as you say it brings to an end for
continuous days of evidence from the
actor and we are expecting to hear next
week from his former partners
the actress were known a rider and
Vanessa Paradis and then towards the end
of next week as well we expect to hear
from Amber Heard herself